y miles de hectáreas arden en portugal
los incendios forestales que se
desataron la semana pasada azotan el
norte y el centro del país en la ciudad
más afectada los bomberos dicen que las
llamas están ya controladas pero las
autoridades instar a los residentes a
mantenerse alerta con más temperaturas
abrasadoras esta semana
en los próximos días vamos a
experimentar un calor que nos pone en
riesgo máximo y por tanto cualquier
descuido puede provocar un incendio
realmente peligroso y si esto ocurre no
habrá forma en portugal ni en el mundo
para extinguir incendios de esta
intensidad
la ola de calor azota la península
ibérica en españa las temperaturas están
superando los 42 grados
terrible terrible
super pero bueno como te digo hay que
trabajar tengo una niña
la gente también se está sofocando en
francia las ciudades del suroeste de
mont-de-marsan toulouse y pop tienen
temperaturas de 34 a 35 grados y eso no
es todo pues las temperaturas seguirán
subiendo por lo menos hasta el miércoles
y se espera que el máximo sea al final
de la semana reino unido no se ha
librado del intenso calor varias
regiones han vivido ya sus días más
calurosos del año con algunas
temperaturas que superan los 30 grados